genau also ich möchte über die
Verkehrswende sprechen und vor allem
auch über die Frage wir wollen wir denn
die Mobilität der Zukunft gestalten so
dass nicht nur Autos auf ihre Kosten
kommen und sich sicher und frei bewegen
können durch die Stadt sondern auch alle
anderen Menschen die mit dem Fahrrad zu
Fuß oder mit dem ÖPNV unterwegs sind und
leider haben wir mit Verkehrsminister
Wissing jemanden der gar nicht genug
dafür tut dass wir unsere Klimaziele im
Verkehr einhalten und dass wir von der
autodominanz wegkommen und das hat auch
der klimabeirat der Bundesregierung im
erst vor kurzem bestätigt in seinem
Sofortprogramm dass dies bei weitem
nicht ausreicht um die Klimaziele bis
2030 einzuhalten und ja ich persönlich
hatte große Hoffnung gesetzt mit der mit
der Ampel dass dort nach 16 Jahren
Stillstand endlich mal ein bisschen
Bewegung reinkommt aber das war leider
nicht der Fall und ja ich hatte es ja
schon erwähnt ich habe drei Jahre in den
Niederlanden gelebt und habe dort die
Erfahrung gemacht wie viel
Lebensqualität wir alle doch
hinzugewinnen können wenn wir nicht so
aufs Auto gucken können wenn es auch
einfach möglich ist ohne Kampfradler zu
sein sich durch die Stadt bewegen zu
können und das war eine wunderbare
Erfahrung das möchte ich nicht missen
und sehe nicht ein warum ich jetzt hier
in Deutschland darauf verzichten soll
das heißt sie sind jetzt wohl enttäuscht
von den Grünen
ich war sehr enttäuscht
als ich gehört habe dass die Grünen
nicht das Verkehrsministerium kriegen
damit hatte ich eigentlich gerechnet und
das ist dann Herr Wissing gleich bekommt
dann bekommt der gleich mit der
Schlagzeile auf sich aufmerksam gemacht
hat er sei doch der Anwalt der
Autofahrer also das war ein
rabenschwacher Tag für mich und leider
ist das auch Programm also wir sehen
nicht dass Herr Wissing die großen Dinge
anpackt und Tempolimit ist eigentlich
eine symboldebatte es ist eine sehr
wichtige Maßnahme aber viel wichtiger
wäre es dass wir die Subvention
abschaffen die 30 Milliarden jährlich in
den Autoverkehr fließen und das ist mit
Herr wissen leider nicht zu machen also
wenn ich das jetzt zusammenfassen kann
sie wollen eben unbedingt Tempolimit
haben auf den Autobahnen und sie wollen
aus unseren deutschen Städten das Auto
eigentlich am liebsten komplett
verbannen wirtschaftlich überhaupt
möglich
wir haben eine große Autoindustrie und
viel hängt an dieser Autoindustrie die
verdient auch viel Geld die nimmt auch
die autofahrerzahlen auch viele Steuern
also auf den längstlichen
aber dahinter steckt ja finde ich auch
wieder das Thema Verbot und da bin ich
genauso wie beim Thema Cannabis einfach
da bin ich nicht dabei wir können nicht
mit Verboten hantieren ich würde ihnen
total zustimmen wenn sie sagen okay das
Auto ist eine Dreckschleuder so wie es
im Moment gebaut wird und wir müssen
diese Emissionen vermeiden aber dann
sage ich doch in einem VW oder einem BMW
jetzt baut mir ein Auto dass diese
Emissionen nicht hat und das vermeiden
und das ist doch eigentlich genau der
richtige Weg dann können wir auch mit
diesem Vehikeln fahren und mal nebenbei
es gibt viele Gründe dafür auch in der
Mobilität sie zu erhalten es gibt
Menschen die leben nicht in Städten die
brauchen ein Auto
bin ich ich habe auch viele Kinder wenn
ich mir in einer Stadt fahre und das
Auto ist voll was soll ich denn machen
wenn ich am Rand stehen bleibe und in
der Bahn muss das geht einfach nicht das
ist nicht praktikabel und ab zum Schluss
autofahren macht auch Spaß also
bitteschön
warum sollen wir denn den Menschen
diesen Spaß den sie offenbar empfinden
manche sind auch immer noch stolz auf
ihr Auto manche putzen das jeden Samstag
die wollen das warum wollen wir Ihnen
das nehmen das ist doch eigentlich der
falsche
Firma freie Fahrt für freie Bürger war
das glaube ich ne das war was anderes
das da das war Freude am Fahren aber es
ist in der Tat so es leben ja nicht alle
Menschen in den Städten also ich finde
grundsätzlich würde ich es ist ja eine
schöne Sache wenn man sagt man kann man
hat Fußgängerzonen oder solche
Geschichten aber es muss das Leben ohne
das Leben muss ja praktikabel sein und
abgesehen jetzt sagen wir mal von dem
freiheitsaspekt der für mich auch der
wichtigste ist eigentlich nicht dass ich
mich Frage mit welchem Recht nehmen
sollen wir sollten wir den Menschen
etwas verbieten eigentlich
ist es einfach nicht praktikabel weil
der Großteil der Menschen in Deutschland
lebt ja nicht in Großstädten also wenn
ich in Berlin hier bin irgendwie dann
brauche ich auch kein Auto in den
meisten Großstädten kommt man eigentlich
auch viel besser mit öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln zurecht das sehe ich
völlig ein aber ich wohne zum Beispiel
auch in dem Randgebiet aber für Kinder
das ist überhaupt nicht praktikabel ein
Leben es ist für viele ältere Leute
überhaupt ist sozusagen die einzige
Mobilität die Sie vielleicht noch haben
und deswegen finde ich ein bisschen mehr
Respekt eigentlich auch der persönlichen
Lebensführung gegenüber von von den
Leuten dass das eine persönliche
Entscheidung ist der eine steckt viel
gerne das eine der andere steckt viel
Geld in sein Auto und in der Tat die
Straßen und so weiter werden wir zahlen
alle nicht unerheblich Steuern für all
das was an Infrastruktur gemacht wird
und die Infrastruktur für Fußgänger für
wird ja nicht besteuert die für
Radfahrer wird auch nicht besteuert also
das ist so ja also wir brauchen das gar
nicht gegenrechnen
jetzt sehr sehr viele Punkte gefallen
ich möchte sie gern alle mal abarbeiten
zum Thema Verbote und Freiheit das kann
ich vielleicht zusammenfassen die
Freiheit des einen ist auch immer die
Freiheit des anderen und in Berlin und
erstmal ich rede nicht über autofreies
Land ich rede über autofreie Städte also
das ist eine Debatte die müssen wir
differenzieren da möchte ich aber einmal
ganz kurz Einparken
diesen Punkt machen und in Berlin leben
60% der Haushalte im Innenstadtbereich
haben überhaupt keine Auto das heißt die
Mehrheit besitzt kein Auto und diese
Leute werden in ihrer Freiheit
eingeschränkt sich so vorzudenken wie
sie wollen natürlich fahren Sie mal mit
Fahrrad durch Berlin
ein Auto können aber nicht weil sie auch
kein Parkplatz haben vor der Tür und
deswegen kein Auto anschaffen also sie
behaupten ja jetzt einfach nur dass 60
Prozent der Leute quasi kein Auto wollen
das ist ein sehr Besitz ich glaube ein
sehr viele einfache es sich gar nicht
mehr leisten können Autos heutzutage
wahnsinnig teuer geworden allein schon
einen Führerschein allein schon
Führerschein zu machen es wahnsinnig
teuer natürlich der ÖPNV ist deutlich
billiger als Autofahren immer noch
Benzin
heutzutage wissen wir wie es und durch
die Decke gegangen ist diese also da
haben wir eine riesen Problem auch also
genau also zu diesen ich wollte noch mal
diesen freiheitspunkt machen es gibt
auch eine Freiheit jenseits des Autos ne
wo Menschen auch ihre Freiheitsrechte
wahrnehmen wollen und die werden mit der
Fülle an Autos die wir in den Städten
haben leider mit Füßen getreten und zu
dem steuerpunkt also das ist ja alles
mal ausgerechnet worden ne Autos Zahlen
ungefähr 40 Milliarden steuern die durch
Mineralölsteuer alles mögliche reinkommt
der Staat zahlt in der gesamten
Aufrechterhaltung der Infrastruktur 70
Milliarden also das ist eine Differenz
von 30 Milliarden und das sind die
Umwelt und Klimaschäden noch gar nicht
aber das Argument
Freude ein bisschen Spaß am Leben dass
man aber auch mal sagt man muss
vielleicht ein kompromisten Kompromiss
hätte gerne auch als Radfahrer Spaß am
Leben und aber das wird doch alles
ausgebaut die Radfahrwege werden
ausgebaut kann man nicht nebeneinander
leben nein im Moment ist das nicht
möglich weil das Auto 70% der gesamten
Fläche wegnimmt obwohl es nur für 25%
der die verantwortlich ist in Berlin das
ist eine das ist eine Schieflage und ja
es geht um flächengerechtigkeit dass die
Menschen die den ÖPNV nutzen ja
flächengerechtigkeit weil das Auto zu
viel Fläche wegnimmt könnt ihr jetzt
noch für alle an auf Kosten aller
anderen ich könnte jetzt noch wahnsinnig
lange über das Thema diskutieren einmal
nur eine Ja oder Nein Frage haben sie
einen Führerschein ja fahren Sie Auto
ich bin auf dem Land groß geworden ich
habe dort meinen Führerschein gemacht
tatsächlich ich fahre hier in Berlin
kein Auto ich habe kein Auto ich fahre
jeden Tag Rad fahren Sie alle gern mal
wenn sie nicht davon überzeugt sind mal
eine Stunde lang mit dem Fahrrad durch
Mitte und dann werden Sie vielleicht ein
bisschen nachsichtiger sein wenn es
möglich wäre dass alle
Verkehrsteilnehmer mal in Frieden
miteinander nebeneinander leben können
das würde ich mir auf jeden Fall
wünschen ich habe nämlich das Gefühl
dass das momentan eigentlich eher Krieg
auf dem Straßen ist ob eine kriegen wir
das dann tatsächlich irgendwann mal
gelöst ich danke Ihnen sehr für diese
Runde es hat viel Spaß gemacht